what you're just happy we're SEO and
stuff
Darren good mood today seriously
that's why tournament
did you see that I like basically played
with one arm yeah yeah I literally
played I really hurt myself lifting
right now I'm on aspirin I don't think
medicine so anything like like ever so
like I said okay yeah it's right it's
better but then you were far from
lifting yeah and then you were fine next
day like two days yeah I think that's
I'm hoping that's the case all right all
right thank you I don't need to see him
I'm just gonna go okay ready yep one 110
[Music]
[Music]
this is
Gary B on this episode we talk about why
people are scared about snapchat we talk
ego and I talked to my future
grandchildren hey everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 110 of
the askgaryvee show I'm in a very very
good mood because Andy's in a good mood
he just came in and he's in a very good
mood holy crap you cut did you get your
headphones ooh yeah
tiger like let's just own it in here
this is from basketball this morning
Vicki Singh was that on the last play
that ended the game you won the game on
that play I'm impressed with you hello
Andy um AJ got married this weekend it
was tremendous that was massively
enjoyable one of the best weekend's of
my entire life
I am in good spirits there's kind of
good stuff going on with business I'm
extremely fired up for the askgaryvee
show and the podcast you've been
noticing if you're paying attention over
the last two or three days I've been
really pushing the podcast I've decided
that I want to shoot up the rankings on
the iTunes score number 14 today 13 in
the business section I wanna be number
one but Ferriss is gonna own that he's
like all in the video siphons I notice
in a lot of comments people are going to
the video because I get it
super tracked and very charismatic on
video I get that but really want to give
a huge shout out to everybody who's
listening right now in a commute and
more importantly vaynernation serious
right hook alert d-roc do something
right hook alert like make something so
I can start doing that more often
information serious right book
[Music]
even if you're not gonna listen to it
I'll take the download because I'm
hacking I want to shoot up the ranks coz
the discovery for people seeing me who
don't know who I am which is believe it
or not 99% of the world is an
opportunity there and so I'm enjoying
that I'm also very seriously considering
answering a unique question every single
episode exclusively to the podcast first
it'd be good because for the people then
they don't have to listen through the
whole thing so maybe we do it first
maybe I start the show with like yours
they maybe even before the intro d-roc
I'm like yours the exclusive answer this
way for the people that are really
hardcore that want to hear every goddamn
answer they can just listen to that part
on the podcast and they move on with
their merry way if they're video
watching so a little hacking going on on
my end my Instagram game is up 110,000
one hundred six thousand followers right
now serious excited about that and just
really fired up about the show really
enjoying the process you guys know I
love the journey so many new fans
popping up because of this show and
that's super humbling and I appreciate
it so big shout out leave in the
comments on YouTube and Facebook if you
are somebody who just discovered my
content in the last six months or less
I'd like to triple down at my thank-yous
and appreciation and all you oh geez you
know how much love I have for you but
would love to get a little emoji
high-five to some new peeps
stunwin let's get into the show
indie on vacation this is old school
it's a throwback Mun Tuesday
what's Steam asking the questions let's
go Chad asks at what point in time if at
all should a brand not use social media
Steve yeah Chad great question uh you
know the funny thing is is all that
social media is is another first of all
social media is a term a slang term for
the current state of the internet right
now the term we used only six or seven
years ago was web 2.0 sites now we call
them social media sites we may call them
something else in
future mobile native you know virtual
this that there's always a term to talk
about the twenty to thirty sites that
matter social media sites happen to mean
the sites that people actually go to the
apps that people actually go to in a
mobile-first world which is what we live
in now and so they the people confused
if there's something there is the thing
called social media there isn't I mean
anything that's a Content site now
anything that like people refer to like
podcast a social media it's just a term
of relevancy and so it's a communication
portal right look you know and there's
some high high high-end brands that
think if they're on Twitter or snapchat
or Instagram or Facebook that they they
cheapen their brand equity I would say
Apple right Apple is a brand that does
very little I still think they're doing
basically nothing on social or at least
definitely not on Twitter I don't think
right like like so you know look do I
think that there is a place where brands
should not do it only if it's a stick if
it's a very well-thought-out we are so
exclusive we're going against the grain
and they make it part of their overall
thing that they emphasize in other
channels of communication their lack of
being there in may position to a small
group that is anti-establishment that
they think that's cool and and so but
more and more what people need to
recognize is that social media is going
through a legitimacy curve right now
over the next five to ten years this
will be the establishment Facebook and
Twitter and pin one I don't know that's
what I'm worried about Facebook and
Instagram and snapchat they're gonna be
the establishment they're you know it's
like banner ads or the Internet itself
it's just gonna be the establishment my
friends and so I think eventually that's
going to run out it's it's if you want
to sell something you need to be able to
communicate to the world and if
everybody's eyes and ears are in a
certain place called the internet I
think you need to be there and I think I
think you have a tough argument to
justify the upside versus the downside
of not communicating in the portals
where people are living oh I know Ben
Phillips hey Gary I got a question for
you why are so many people scared
Chadd especially in the marketing field
a lot of them say they don't understand
it but I feel like that's a cop-out
what do you think Ben I think it's
ironic that you wore a yellow shirt when
you asked that question I wonder if that
was strategic if it was a big DAPs to
you also enjoying the beard and the
glasses look you look really legit I
think that people are not practitioners
I would argue that ninety-five percent
of people in marketing ninety-five
percent of people in marketing at
digital and social agencies on the
brands and the business sides actually
don't know how snapchat works actually
I've never went through all four screens
of snapchat to the left to the right
twice and the camera itself literally
have not done that literally I would
argue that 70% of marketers have never
touched one of the discover tabs on
snapchat because they are just not
practitioners and snapchat has a context
and a cadence and a system that is not
native to a lot of people because it's
left-to-right not up and down like all
the other apps and so there's some
learning like it actually takes four to
five minutes of thought and energy to
really understand how snapchat works if
you've never used it before and that's
about four to five minutes worth of
actual practitioner ship that most
people don't apply they like the
headline read that the kids send sex
pictures to each other and they like to
be old white men even if they're not old
white men right plenty of 23 year old
has spanic women acting like old white
men because they're not practitioner
slang term old white men to let you suck
[ __ ] like you're not putting in the work
you're tired you're not innovating you
stink you stink you stink and so why do
I think people are scared of snapchat
because they stink because most people
suck at marketing most people just want
to do what they've already known they
don't evolve I wake up every morning of
my life trying to put myself out of
business because it's a lot better to do
that than have somebody else do it for
me and that's how I live and that's how
I'm gonna live until I'm an old white
man acting like a 14 year old chick
alright cuz that's just the way I'm
gonna roll and so as you can see I got a
little excited on this answer because it
strikes a real nerve to what's actually
happening in society because as we are
living through the Second Industrial
Revolution
the real cultural shift of the last half
century this internet thing getting to
maturity with mobile devices at scale
computing on our fingertips at all times
at scale the whole kitten caboodle
society the whole thing everyone all of
us everyone when that hits and that's
here and it's starting to really hit
everything changes forever
everything everything marketing just
happens to be the part that I'm most
interested in talking about Mike wants
to know are you building an ecosystem or
an ecosystem
Michael this is true this is a great
great question
and I think the answer is both I think
the true answer is both I think that I'd
created a infrastructure of free content
and interaction and organization that
has created an ecosystem it's it's super
hard to argue I mean way too crushed it
comes out the book that follows the 400
people the which is 400 of the 4,000
people that read crush it and their
lives changed go read the comments in
the Facebook posts and in the Instagram
posts around this show of people
literally in the last 30 days because
I'm reading Moll just talking about how
like weird like watching a hundred
episodes of this has changed their life
they make more money like real life
stuff so that's an ecosystem on the flip
side it's very central around a human
being right me and that's an ego system
so I I think the answer is both and I
think that you know I think like
anything in life it there's a very fine
line I often use you know Oprah to a
bunch of spammy gurus she just walked
the fine line of inspiration and
motivation just right to create all-time
great billionaire ship and like all-time
great impact
whereas gosh if she just turned an inch
in the other direction and if you look
at her early career she probably was in
that lane and I think what she was able
to squeak it a little bit more to the
left it took her to the stratosphere
look I think I'm walking a very fine
line and I think that um
I think I'm walking it properly and I
think I believe that because I just
clearly know myself fast and know my
motivations and I think that if you were
to intimately look under the hood of my
actions and career you would see all the
dollars I'm leaving on the table which I
think usually tend to be the the
motivator that forces people to get on
the wrong side of the road of this eco
ego system that you talk about and so I
think the answer is both
I very much thrive off the attention the
pressure the admiration the trolling and
hating it's all part of it and and I
think I'm capable and I've brought
enough shoulders and puffy enough chests
to be able to deal with it and so the
answer is both and I think done right
done properly by all standards of a
seven-person jory I think it's the way
to pull off great legacy and that's what
I'm trying to do what do you think Steve
I agree
seriously yeah thanks Andrew wants to
know do you see skill sharing and
teaching people skills as an alternative
to education coming up in the sharing
economy Andrew I do very simply the
answer is yes very simply I believe the
Internet is gonna squeeze everything in
the middle that doesn't provide value
out of business over a 100-year period
and so everything's in the middle really
between you and a thing and the
education system is in the middle
between you and actually having the next
chapter of your life in play monetizing
if you really think about it at its
grand scheme you go to school in theory
historically the way it's been thought
of to set you up to monetize your thing
I mean as we know so many people go
through the schooling and then realize
they don't want to be a lawyer or a
doctor or whatever they've been learning
to do and they reset and they go into
the open market I think that that needs
to be thought about I think that needs
to really be thought about and we've
never lived in a time where I mean look
it's guys at 30 years old I began the
first seed of thought that I should
speak
to the world about something that
happened to be wine at the time I mean
there wasn't things like this podcast
the show or the billions of pieces of
content that live now that educate
people at a level that we've never seen
before if there is anyone if there's
anyone that believes that unionized
human beings and old textbooks can
outperform education of information and
thinking to the vast majority of human
society and the Internet then you are a
lost human being lost with a capital L
and so now what needs to happen is some
organization I mean look I actually
believe the following statement I
actually believe one of these singular
reasons that universities are in play is
the romantic point of view that the
parents of our current generation view
on the institution and I truly believe
it's going to take only two more
generations not necessarily mine but my
kids have no prayer of valuing Harvard
and Stanford on a community college to
the level it's valued by my parents no
shot in hell I'm putting it on I don't
like to predict but I'm putting it right
here on film you know Big Ups to my
little you know grandchildren that are
watching this now 50 years from now
hey little Sarah I love you and and you
know I just uh actually Sarah is gonna
be so out of date by then hey zaboo kheh
big fan hope we're watching this
together and so you know I I think that
you know the skill shares the Khan
Academy's the endless content on YouTube
the podcasts the tremendous impact that
all the content that's living right now
is having on the younger generation and
how they will think that they right now
we have 15 year olds that think their
two cents on every thought our public
domain that they need to add their two
cents what do you think when they become
educated through school and not school
what they're gonna share and how it's
just gonna be so much information plus
our system right now is so predicated on
teaching our kids to memorize something
and then regurgitate it a couple of
weeks later in a world where
all that information is that their
fingertips you know nobody gives a [ __ ]
who the 18th President of the United
States is or or what's the warmest
planet I could tell you one [ __ ]
second you idiots
I mean it's just stupid I know what do
you guys got it oh my god
lot of gray there at the end there for
you a little black and white action for
you d rock question of the day I'm
actually curious about this so answer
quickly because I know this is going in
motion right now do you think that the
Warriors hold on and win the
championship or do you think LeBron
pulls off a store at Game six and Game
seven victories I want to see in the
comments
who's gonna close out this NBA Finals
I'm curious also Part B did you sign up
for the podcast yes or no put a number
two in the comment section and say yes
or no you keep asking questions I'll
keep answering them
yes let's do it
cool find someone I can just go to the
fifth question that we did master in the
show there's a fifth question you were
running along so I just got it yeah
great should we do the fifth and just
plug it in no that'd be you know what
gray this whole thing do you rock not
actually don't gray it play it anyway
you know what I mean and then let's do
this fifth question for the podcast
ready you're just gonna do the audio
[Music]
[Music]